welcome to this video playing civil
civil who came going for the sicilian
for a change maybe the Kalashnikov okay
I can he actually allows me to play that
very often they play Bishop b5 almost
like that okay well this is a very
comfortable way to to play for black can
I even play night before here let's
let's play quickie em looks like it
gives me gives me the bishops on a good
transformation okay so I have the bishop
pair okay and he opened up the position
which is also quite nice for the black
in general the only issue is of course
that i'm now not really behind in
development not much i was just thinking
maybe he can just grab this pawn it's
terribly materialistic but maybe he can
do it no maybe he can I mean it's
nothing that that scares me much I'm so
active that it's probably not very
important but I may be really should
have attended this okay Bishop f6 is an
easy way to probably get get material
back
yeah i also have root d8 which i can
flick into to win another tempo the
other problem is that I'm very left
getting the porn back there means of
taking on c3 and this is giving up my
best piece on f6 so it's probably only
leading to a data quality yeah I'm not
sure what you should do it's not very
comfortable to play
yeah that's done the super materialistic
way I briefly had considered it but hmm
looks it looks suspicious maybe you can
do it 94 some as a threat it's a threat
IAM
maybe get to get out of this keep you
two attacked
yeah the the bad thing is if you if you
look at the position it's clear that
black has some very very decent
compensation for the pawn and I could
could have gotten essentially the same
position without being a pawn down
pretty sure about that um really you can
what about rook the eight now how do you
protect the night Quincy to Bishop five
will be three hmm
you can also take him be takes y'all
can't come on I know I weighed if i go
here Quincy to ship lexi has night takes
okay men come on keep it simple Knight
takes Queen B to us is very comfortable
and be takes maybe just Roxy form rooks
e4e a double attacking the night might
be to roots III getting it back with an
active position the night is really a
very very unlucky in peace I cannot
cannot be too i just take the night yeah
I'm really out of shape here came go
here and how do you protect the night
now this is gone he needed to take with
the night
has really lost this piece he needed to
take what the night queen bee 2nite you
form something something like that okay
so we get to an end game with with the
extra piece
so it should be three just winning the
pawn probably
look b3s is exchanging one book and
after that winning the pawn that's even
simpler takes and Bishop d7 and then
it's gone
okay not quite sure what the point is
I'm I may even have more time on the
clock
the easiest here is to set up the King
side as I'm doing now with the bishop on
f5 and then Luke here and rooks it to
getting on the second rank this will
activate the rook I changes the diamond
check
okay so let's check now how to to get
some progress Bishop to f1 would be
would be helpful I can also activate the
King only yeah King f4 key for something
to be avoided okay but here but the look
moving away he has given up control over
g two white those eyes yeah whatever um
yeah it was a bit silly for me to give
up a 70 I mean here this is really a
dream position it's it's it so it's an
open position where I have two bishops
and which means black is already much
more comfortable but I really shouldn't
have keep it away a seven I can't
basically yeah I don't know maybe I can
start with Queen a5 Queen 85 s maybe
rookie five so maybe a move like this
and then Luke da it I really but I need
to do is yes exchange exchange some
heavy pieces zone then I can basically
torture them forever with my two bishops
against bishop at night of course the
symmetrical pawn structure is not very
helpful for me but still it's just very
nice and so yeah I just gave away the
point for no particular reason it's
still very very much compensation airy
stop where she gives black a slight edge
despite being the pawn down and here it
starts starts to get get tricky he must
play Knight c3 back now 94 was really a
bad idea and this is this is already
problematic okay rook da de stronger ah
oh very strong move very strong of
course I saw this but I then I thought
Quincy two and then Bishop takes Knight
takes is not good of course but I have
this move
strong that's easy to miss young easy to
miss move now attacking the night from
the side and what should he do if he
plays be three I can take and then pick
up the c3 Bishop with a with a win
basically great great variation I didn't
see that ok so here he must take with
the night then after this it's clear
that black is more comfortable the a
porn is especially weekend I'm quicker
on the open files but winning is another
matter where this is just losing the
piece for for nothing auntie continued a
while without any particular reason but
yeah him he's just lost the night funny
ok thanks for watching